the first category is let's look at
information technologies
now as big a deal as the last 30 years
were
we got another 30 years to go i think of
it as infotech stage
two and the first big thing to focus on
is universal
connectivity the next 10 years we're
basically going to get the second half
of the planet
online we've got all kinds of
operational projects trying to do this
low orbit satellites like starlink from
elon musk
and we've got all kinds of things trying
to also boost up the bandwidth to get to
5g
so let's think that one through if you
really think about it
looking ahead asia still has about half
its people
are not online africa in the middle east
has about two-thirds still not online
latin america about 40 percent to go so
a continued driver of a technology
expansion and off that an economic boom
is just
on the same mechanism that we saw play
out in the last 30 years now
think about that for a moment in 2000
you really only had a handful of
americans online
by 2030 you're gonna have everyone
on the planet online now on the backs
of all those global connections is going
to come ai and so we're starting to see
now how ai can be used it's an
incredible extension of human
capabilities
but we're eventually going to get to
ubiquitous ai
we're going to have all digital data
it's going to be captured in the cloud
it's going to be accessible to everyone
at all times and ai's going to plumb
that in myriad ways
one of the ways it's going to actually
do it
is getting to natural language
translation by ai particularly this is
going to be useful with the second half
of the world coming online who are not
educated elites not able to speak a
second language
the business language of english so what
i think we're also going to see here is
a secondary effect
of this connections of what i would call
accelerated innovation
innovation is that making
cross-connections between people from
different perspectives different fields
different expertises
and if you start to think through the
impact of that kind of
cross-fertilization not just across
ideas but across cultures across classes
all this mosh pit of cross connection is
going to happen in the next 10 years
now the flip side of this is kind of
related to a forward projection of
america's law
it's hard to predict how humans are
going to leverage a powerful new tool
like ai
too many people are focused on the
negative possibilities
how many are factoring it into our
abilities to solve our biggest
challenges
we will need ai and i think we will
fully use ai over the next 30 years to
solve these biggest challenges
i think it's going to end up a net
positive and to our benefit
for sure